sure my question concerns what you said
about democracy not being so good
handling the chronic problem yeah and
I'm wondering if you can offer what you
think would be solutions to a chronic
problem and if globalization can help or
hinder and if religion comes into play
at all in okay so let me set the
religion piece aside first and address
the other parts I think that you know in
in the kind of political theorizing that
interests me the question is always
compared to what so democracy is not
very good at handling chronic problems
but compared to what you know we might
have thought that in the boatloads of
literature in the that's come out of the
analytical tradition of political theory
which which tells you why democracies
are not good at at handling all kinds of
chronic problems like tragedy of the
Commons problems public goods provision
and so on but but you know one of the
ironies of the collapse of the Soviet
Union is that we discovered they didn't
handle these things well at all you know
those let the lakes in central Russia
are toxic pets they didn't handle
environmental problems well either so so
democracy is not very good at it but
compared to what and I think that the
answer seems to be certainly not
compared to authoritarian systems so the
really interesting question then becomes
which types of democracies are better
and worse at it and I think that that we
created a democracy here that's not
particularly good at it because we
created a democracy here which doesn't
allow governments to act we built in
what political economists call veto
points all over the place right we
created bicameralism we created
separation of powers we created a
federal system we over-represented
the the small states in the Senate we've
got as weel as we all can watch playing
out now the filibuster rule all of this
stuff makes innovation political
innovation really hard okay and and it's
in an important sense all of it is
anti-democratic because one important
analog at one important reason that that
democracy is desirable is that you have
political competition I I think that if
you want to avoid winner-take-all
politics you really have to have
competitive politics when it take all
politics the kind of monopoly politics
and monopolies are as destructive in
politics as they are in economics we're
not used to thinking that way you know
when people say oh isn't it great this
bipartisan agreement on some bill nobody
stands up and says that's collusion in
restraint of democracy right nobody
stands up and says that but that's
that's really what it is because what
we've created in the u.s. is a system
where the government of the day can only
really govern with the consent of the
opposition you know I don't think I
quite follow the idea that if but if the
opposition or the various factions of
opposition come together with a
governing party and agree on something
yeah that that is in any way contrary to
the dictates of democracy now if that's
what happens but if you design a system
where the government cannot act unless
that happens it's a hell of a poor
system in solving big problems I think
that's right so so what just that I
would just let Frederick come in in a
second just let me finish the thought
and and so the thought here would be
that why is competition good in
democracy well that you know there are a
lot of different reasons why competition
is good but one of the reasons is
exactly the same we exactly analogous to
why competition
is good in the economy competition as a
byproduct of competition we get
information right we get information
because the opposition attacks the
government points out the flaws in its
arguments shines light in dark corners
can undermine corruption and so on
whereas if you if you essentially just
have to have a system to get everybody
on board if you figure out what the
distribution of bribes is to do that and
you do it right so I think that that the
better system is the Westminster model
where you have us you have a strong
government and you have an opposition
which is not an ongoing monitor and
participant in in legislation but
whether a government in waiting and and
that government in waiting with its
shadow cabinet and all of that has the
incentive to shine light in dark corners
to expose corruption to you just you
know go and watch Prime Minister's
Questions on online any day the week
will read the British papers and you'll
see what genuine more genuine political
competition is like than what we get
here so i think that that's a more
desirable model it's not perfect but you
know as Churchill said it's the worst
system compared to the others